on vous propose l'analyse de damien
contandriopoulos ce soir sur la question
des inégalités professeur à l'université
de victoria
monsieur compte andriot paulos bonsoir
bonsoir
en quoi la crise de lakovic 19 comme
d'autres crises d'ailleurs vient
accentuer les inégalités sociales je
pense la meilleure explication c'est ça
le on l'a dit beaucoup sur les réseaux
sociaux on est tous dans la même tempête
mais on n'est pas dans le même bateau et
n'importe quel événement qui va venir
changer dans la société où on est
affecté la société que ce soit une crise
économique que ce soit un désastre
naturel
plus on est vulnérable le terme
vulnérable donc plus on a de risques
d'être affectés est ce qu'on voit à
l'échelle mondiale comme vous dites les
zones de conflit les pays les plus
pauvres sont touchés par la famine et
ici au canada les gens qui sont dans les
postes de travail les moins rémunérés
les gens qui sont socialement
vulnérables parce que seul parce qu'avec
des faibles revenus parce qu'avec plus
d'éducation parce que dans des secteurs
plus touchés
tous ces gens là vont être affectés de
façon disproportionnée et une chose qui
est fondamentale en termes de santé
publique c'est de faire attention quand
on déploie des mesures mur à mur comme
ce qu'on fait actuellement d'obtenir
compte du fait que avait donné la même
mesure à tout le monde c'est inéquitable
est-ce qu est-ce que donc les mesures
qui sont annoncées par le gouvernement
fédéral par exemple est ce que vous
considérez qu'elle contribue à augmenter
ou à réduire les inégalités
elles sont définitivement destinées à
limiter les dommages qu'ils ont causés
par les mesures de distanciation
physique et de fermeture économique
convient essais des mesures qui
globalement pour ce que j'en comprends
semble avoir du sens semble que le
meilleur point de référence qu'on peut
regarder c'est 2008 il ya une crise
économique significative peut-être pas
aussi grave que celle qu'on va vivre
mais significative en particulier dans
les pays européens et des bonnes études
en santé publique ont été faites qui
regarde l'impact de ces crises là sur
des indicateurs leur très robuste entre
autres la mortalité est ce qu'on voit
c'est que pour chaque 100 dollars
investis ou retirer des programmes
sociaux dans les pays européens on on
peut lier sa une
une modification de la mortalité toutes
causes confondues de l'ordre de 1% c'est
majeur donc les mesures d'austérité
économique en particulier dans des pays
comme la grèce ou le portugal l'italie
ont tué beaucoup de monde est dans une
situation comme on vit actuellement on
doit essayer de jongler avec différentes
causes de mortalité mais quand on
regarde le virus va tuer des gens ça
fait aucun doute c'est en cours il faut
faire attention que la potentielle
dépression économique qui s'en vient et
qui est en cours
elle tue aussi peu que possible
oui mais en même temps justement le
gouvernement essaie d'aider les gens
présentement à vivre avec ses
conséquences économiques très néfaste il
ya l'aide aujourd'hui aux organismes
communautaires est ce que l'aide du
gouvernement sera selon vous cible bien
justement les plus démunis qui sont les
plus touchés par la crise et peut
ralentir la montée des inégalités aux
actes et je suis pas économiste je suis
spécialisé en santé publique qui sont
les politiques de santé donc est ce que
au niveau économique ça va marcher je
peux pas vous dire au niveau social on
sait que les investissements qui sont
faits très proche des communautés qui
sont relativement décentralisée pilotes
dans les organismes communautaires sont
d'excellents le levier sont les
investissements qui ont plus de chances
d'atteindre leurs cibles que des
investissements qui a aidé les
corporations les grandes compagnies et
qui ont plus de chances de se ramasser
dans les contrats manque très sélect
donc à priori oui
est-ce que face à l'ampleur de la crise
actuelle c'est suffisant c'est une
excellente question
et encore une fois on est dans une
situation où personne à la bonne réponse
on est certain d'avoir les bonnes
réponses vous avez commencé l'interview
sur voudrait confier votre émission je
veux dire sur les nouvelles données
qu'on a sur le taux d'infection qui peut
être beaucoup plus élevé que ce qu'on
pensait niveau de mortalité est plus bas
que ce qu'on pense
et chaque fois ça vient affecter les
paramètres avec lesquels on joue on
essaie de prendre des décisions pour
minimiser la souffrance le nombre de
morts mais là si un des paramètres de
l'équation change
peut-être qu'ils les décisions qui sont
prises sont mauvaises n'importe quel
décideur actuellement je pense doit agir
avec une certaine humilité par rapport à
ce qu'on sait clairement clairement vous
avez tout à fait raison
et là on va amorcer une période où on va
pas on vous en parle de plus en plus de
roue
rires l'économie ou en tout cas de une
période de déconfinement comment on peut
arriver à diminuer l'accroissement des
inégalités dans le processus de décor au
film ans qui va s'amorcer
je pense que c'est probablement moins
sensible que ce qu'on voit actuellement
ces accueils personnellement on parle de
déconfinement on parle du fait qu'on va
tolérer un certaine reprise de la
transmission du virus et pas de toute
façon de le mettre et faut toujours de
revenir à cette équation le virus est là
pour rester donc deux choses l'une où on
atteint qui est un vaccin et on essaie
de minimiser le nombre de gens qui ont
la maladie d'ici à ce qu'on ait un
vaccin soit on pense qu'on aura le
vaccin trop tard essentiellement que
l'épidémie a suivi son cours avant qu'on
lit et dans ces cas là on joue avec à
quel rythme l'économie
le virus se répandant société mais on
peut le prendre d'un côté ou l'autre à
partir du moment où on va réouvrir des
gens vont tomber malade est actuellement
c'est pas comme si on était capable de
protéger ce qu'on veut protéger on voit
actuellement le virus se répand le plus
rapidement l'eau dans les milieux où on
voudrait le moins qu'ils soient ch et
celle des hôpitaux prisons
certaines industries où les gens sont en
contact donc jusqu'à un certain point on
essaye de faire des choix pour contrôler
qui va être affecté quand on peut pas
dire qu'on a super bien réussi jusqu'à
maintenant
non mais là en parlant de réouverture de
l'économie là vous dites vous venez nous
dire que si on attendait de virus on
attendra encore plus longtemps pour
ouvrir l'économie est ce que ça ça
pourrait avoir des effets encore plus
important sur les inégalités sur le sort
de bien
bien des populations c'est si vous avez
une boule de cristal vous fait répondre
à cette question si on attend le vaccin
est ce qu'on va avoir un vaccin s'étant
pas encore avec certitude ce que j'ai
plein d'essais cliniques en cours mais
est ce que le résultat avant impôt
positif on ne sait pas au moment où le
vaccin va arriver à ce que le virus va
toujours être là main mais ce qui aurait
une mutation à ce que le vaccin va être
suffisamment possible de produire
suffisamment grande quantité pour
atteindre les gens qui devraient
atteindre
et quand tout ça va se produire donc on
fait des scénarios 18 mois 2 ans
peut-être que c'est vrai peut-être que
ça ne l'est pas une chose est certaine
c'est que le virus va vite on a les
chiffres sur peut-être 10 à 12% de
certaines régions en france qu'ils sont
qui ont déjà été infectées en deux mois
bon
ça prend pas de grandes capacités de
calcul pour saisir que avant deux ans on
va atteindre et sa tour de 60 % qui sont
présentement les soeurs étaient d'elle
même
absolument on va s'arrêter aussi là
qu'on perd le signal monsieur compte
andriot poulos merci beaucoup pour cet
entretien ce soir merci à vous